bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce lundi 5 juillet le groupe
pétrolier franco belge total fina lance
une offre publique d'échangé sur elf si
l'offre réussit le groupe deviendrait le
quatrième producteur mondial de pétrole
le président jacques chirac en
déplacement à bordeaux appelle les
partis politiques à dépasser les
itinéraires personnels et à lille le
premier ministre lionel jospin affirme
que le cap fixé par le gouvernement ne
changera pas les premiers résultats du
baccalauréat 99 les oraux de rattrapage
pour les uns les joies de la réussite
dès ce soir pour les autres algérie le
président bouteflika permet la
libération des premiers prisonniers
islamistes 5000 personnes sur et grassi
en attendant peut-être la levée de
l'état d'urgence peut être annoncés ce
soir
et puis le tour de france cyclisme
changement de maillot jaune c'est
l'estonien quercy piou qui tentait du
tour l'étape connu quelques instants
dramatiques au passage du gois près de
noirmoutier dans le secteur pétrolier
s'est branle bas de combat depuis
l'annoncé ce matin de la volonté du
groupe total final de lancer une offre
publique d'échangé sur elf aquitaine
c'est une offre publique qualifié d'
inamicale selon l' usage dans ce domaine
puisqu'elle se fait sans avertir les
dirigeants du groupe l
et ça sent la bonne affaire puisque la
bourse de paris a battu tous ses records
aujourd'hui grâce cette action menée par
total
explication jean bernard schmidt et
philippe lui dit
le pdg de total fina peut sourire son
secret aura été bien gardé jusqu'au bout
son raid sur elf aquitaine a surpris
tout le monde à commencer par le pdg de
l'entreprise convoitée qui n'a été mise
au courant que quelques minutes avant
l'annoncé
j'ai laissé des messages pas de
sentiments donc car l'enjeu est de
taille
l'objectif pour total créé le quatrième
groupe pétrolier mondial en prenant le
contrôle de son concurrent direct et ce
par un échange
quatre actions total contre 3 titres elf
regrouper les deux entreprises poserait
plus de 500 milliards de francs et
serait présente sur tous les continents
un rapprochement qui séduit des
analystes en termes de portefeuille
d'activités désactiver portefeuille
d'activités sont relativement
complémentaires dont peu de difficulté à
attendre de ce côté là même s'il faudra
évidemment procéder à la restructuration
et sur le plan humain il faut savoir que
la culture d entreprise est relativement
proche par conséquent elle va y avoir
assez peu difficultés de ce type à ce
niveau là pour les syndicats si les
complémentarités existe bien entre les
deux entreprises
cette tentative de fusion fait quand
même courir un risque à l'emploi le fait
que la direction d'elf soit totalement
opposé au projet le fait que le pdg
total apparaissent comme ayant décidé un
peu seul set cette opération nous semble
très dommageable et très risqué en
matière de conséquence sociale puisque
l'argent qui sera mis dans la bataille
boursière n'ira pas à des
investissements industriels qui favorise
l'emploi au bout du compte total et elf
réuni ce sont 130 mille employés
la fusion entraînerait 4000 suppressions
d'emplois dont la moitié en france mais
sans licenciement ce soir le
gouvernement a annoncé qu'il ne
s'opposerait pas à l'opération
la bourse elle a salué leur aide
l'action elf a grimpé de plus de 21 %
aujourd'hui
alors rappelons le si cette stratégie du
groupe franco-belge sautel fille n'a
réussi l'ensemble ainsi réalisé avec
elle se classera en quatrième position
dans le monde pour l'ensemble de ses
activités
il faut préciser que le plus intéressant
dans le dossier f c'est tout le secteur
de l'exploration et de la production en
afrique le groupe total elle serait
alors le premier sur ce continent
comment taire eric masi et françois
granier c'était le 1er décembre dernier
les pétroliers exxon et mobil annoncé
leur mariage au même instant de l'autre
côté de l'atlantique les européens total
et final les imiter avec ces deux
fusions le gigantesque mouvement de
concentration de l'industrie pétrolière
s'accélérer total d'ailleurs ne marque
pas de pause en cherchant à absorber son
rival français elf pour l'heure
fragilisé il ya une situation
psychologique assez fragile du fait des
grèves qui encourt lui fait des affaires
qui avaient cours du fait de l'échec de
deux acquisitions celle de fil à essen
de saga depuis un an le prix du baril de
brut a chuté de 40%
il est même descendu sous la barre des
10 dollars c'est cette chute des cours
qui a réduit la rentabilité des sociétés
pétrolières et déclencher ainsi les
regroupements objectifs recherchés faire
des économies d'échelle et partager les
risques d'une prospection toujours plus
coûteuses car les réserves de pétrole
potentiels sont maintenant situées en
mer et les coûts d'exploitation ils sont
deux fois plus cher que sur terre depuis
peu le prix du pétrole remonte mais les
concentrations continue d'autre but que
la rentabilité sont donc recherchées le
besoin de disposer d'un plus grand
pouvoir de négociation face aux
principaux états producteurs de pétrole
et de gaz
et puis la facilité qu'il y à un
racheter une production et des réserves
déjà existantes ce qui permet de réduire
grandement le risque de l'exploration
mais la taille limite de ces super géant
semble être atteintes car revers de la
médaille
ils sont de plus en plus difficiles à
contrôler selon le ministère de
l'économie la mise en vente des actions
du crédit lyonnais a été
particulièrement fructueuse les demandes
sont en effet trois fois supérieure aux
56 millions de titres proposés en
politique le président de la république
et le premier ministre étaient tous les
deux en déplacement ce lundi pour le
chef de l'état c'était à bordeaux la
ville dont le maire est alain juppé
l'occasion pour monsieur chirac
d'appeler les familles politiques au
delà des itinéraires personnels être
porteuse d'un projet de société cohérent
fin de citation des propos de monsieur
chirac reportage véronique saint-olivier
jean cornu
reprendre l'initiative rattraper un
électorat déboussolé par les européennes
retrouvez d'une famille politique éclaté
sur cela jacques chirac a choisi
bordeaux alain juppé à ses côtés un
soutien affiché à son ancien premier
ministre à combrée par l' affaire des
emplois fictifs de la mairie de paris
est l'occasion pour le président de la
république d'évoquer la reconstruction
de l'opposition l'idée d'un grand parti
du président est enterré aujourd'hui
jacques chirac se veut admettre notre
démocratie doit permettre à un débat
fécond et structurée entre les familles
politiques clairement identifiés cela
mérite que l'on y investissent du temps
de la capacité d'écouté de l'imagination
de l'énergie et ceci bien sûr au delà
des itinéraires personnels au déjeuner
qui réunit les élus du département le
président de l'udf applaudi des deux
mains cette reconnaissance d'une
opposition plurielle mais il en refuse
de leadership âge as tu iras c'est au
chef de l'état les responsabilités de
chef de l'état qui représente tous les
français pas seulement les français de
l'opposition au delà des partis jacques
chirac veut maintenant surtout
promouvoir ce qu'il appelle la
démocratie locale
illustration avec cette visite à
l'hôpital où médecins et associations
privées travaillent ensemble ce n'est
pas un hasard au moment où lionel jospin
des fentes à lille la loi des 35 heures
jacques chirac revendique à l'averse ici
la multiplication des initiatives
locales sur le terrain de comportement
deux approches qui pourrait aussi
devenir deux positionnements lors de la
prochaine campagne présidentielle
et d'autre part le président jacques
chirac s'est déclarée favorable à une
loi programme permettant en france le
développement des langues régionales le
président avait récemment refusé de
modifier la constitution mais il
souhaite que de nouvelles mesures soient
mises en oeuvre pour aider ces langues
régionales dans le domaine par exemple
de l'enseignement de la culture ou de la
vie économique
le chef du gouvernement de son côté
était à lille la ville de pierre mauroy
et de martine aubry il y fut surtout
question de réduction du temps de
travail et d'emploi jeunes de domaines
dans lesquels monsieur jospin n'entend
pas dit il changer de cap pas plus qu'il
ne souhaitait aujourd'hui évoquer autre
chose que l'emploi
reportage alban nicosie et dominique
maes pour le plus grand plaisir de
martine aubry lionel jospin a sorti
aujourd'hui de sa panoplie sa blouse
d'anciens professeurs d'économie thème
des travaux pratiques
la réduction du temps de travail
illustration à travers la visite d'une
société de confiserie industriel près de
lille
575 personnes travaillent ici un accord
permettra l'embauché d'ici un an de 35
salariés supplémentaires
toute la journée lionel jospin a martelé
le même message la lutte contre le
chômage passe par les 35 heures aux
entreprises sont performantes comme
ailleurs elles sont désireuses
d'améliorer leur compétitivité comme
ailleurs elles sont soucieuses de leur
rentabilité
elles signent des accords de réduction
du temps de travail parce qu'elle y
trouve aussi au delà des incitations qui
les y encouragent leurs intérêts bien
compris
au coeur de ce plaidoyer le patronat
lionel jospin est venu à lille affiché
son soutien à martine aubry
injustement critiqué selon lui par le
medef déjà le matin dans une école de la
ville ils étaient côte à côte pour
entendre une douzaine d'emplois jeunes
leur raconter leurs activités
culturelles et de loisirs
ces métiers récents dont l'intitulé
parfois bret a souri
à partir du moment où ils auront prouvé
leur utilité où ils auront répondu à un
besoin presque à créer le besoin n'est
créé le métier par rapport aux besoins
l'idée c'est rechercher la pérennisation
en signant ce 200.000e contrat lionel
jospin a voulu donner l'image d'un
premier ministre gestionnaire
sous-entendu je ne suis pas en campagne
électorale et d'ailleurs de quelle
élection ne parlez vous plus de deux
cent mille emplois jeunes créés et donc
avec des secteurs plus réceptifs que
d'autres comme l'éducation nationale et
le monde associatif mais depuis la
création de ces emplois jeunes c'était
en octobre 97 par martine aubry
aucune instance représentative
n'existait les bénéficiaires de ces
emplois jeunes viennent de créer une
association qui leur permet d'échanger
leurs idées et leur expérience la
première s'est réuni à la rochelle mais
elle a déjà fait des petits enfants ce
reportage parmi les emplois jeunes
rochelais de yann fronty et joseph
boulesteix tous ces garçons et ces
filles se rencontrent pour la première
fois qu'il travaille pour l'éducation
nationale dans des hôpitaux pour des
collectivités locales ils ont un point
commun emplois jeunes ici dans cette
salle de la rochelle cej pro une
association créée il ya deux mois qui
les réunit un moyen de se faire entendre
on a des compétences on a des acquis et
on a des savoir faire donc
y'a plus qu'à être reconnu près de deux
ans après leur création en octobre 97
les emplois jeunes se posent des
questions sur leur avenir interrogation
également sur leur statut ou leur droit
se regrouper au sein de cette
association
la première du genre est pour eux un
moyen de devenir des interlocuteurs
privilégiés auprès des élus parce que
c'est important devant une structure qui
fédère en fait c'est les différentes
remarques pour les faire émerger et
faire remonter aux instances isolées
dans le marais poitevin jean pierre n'en
est pas moins très heureux de sa
situation d'emploi jeunes chargés
d'études en environnement il a trouvé le
métier dont il rêvait mais comme ses
camarades il a parfois des doutes et des
questions pour lui djipro doit avant
tout remplir ce rôle d'information
je ne pense pas que ça soit l'intérêt de
cette association d'avoir des
revendications syndicales
moi je suis plutôt à la recherche bien
de discussion de découverte
et puis de pouvoir me renseigner à voir
des gens sur qui je puisse m'appuyer
pour monter un dossier pour tel ou tel
problème relatif à à mon contrat de
travail et déjà cette expérience séduit
de plus en plus de jeunes d'autres
associations calqué sur le même modèle
secret un peu partout en france à lille
lyon ou bordeaux
forte de ce succès djipro la rochelle
compte désormais aller au bout de son
projet devenir une instance
incontournable créer un journal est
embauché un emploi jeune pour tout
coordonner à rouen ce soir représentants
syndicaux et gouvernement doivent signer
un accord d'arrêt des activités des
ateliers et chantiers du havre les ach
fermeront définitivement mois d'octobre
prochain
400 personnes seront licenciées dès le
mois d'août 200 autres d'ici la fin du
mois de novembre pour économiser 62
milliards de francs par an la caisse
nationale d'assurance maladie annoncent
un plan stratégique comprenant 35 mesure
ce plan sera soumis au vote du conseil
d'administration de la cnam le 12
juillet prochain
il prévoit entre autres de réguler les
dépenses de santé ainsi que le
remboursement des patients reportage
cyrille devaud avec jose helvétique
le déficit de la sécurité sociale une
maladie chronique
c'est donc un remède de cheval qui est
proposé économisez jusqu'à 62 milliards
de francs par an premier souci le
contrôle des médecins contrôle des
dépenses
le principe d'une sanction financière
est confirmé pour ceux qui dépassent
leur forfait annuel d'honoraires
contrôle de la répartition géographique
un système de code
à pourrait forcer les médecins à
s'installer dans les quartiers
difficiles et dans les zones rurales
enfin contrôle des compétences la cnam
préconise une évaluation tous les sept
ans en cas de niveau insuffisant les
consultations ne seraient plus
remboursés
une mesure qui fait grincer les dents
des généralistes et le risque c'est que
à partir du moment la sécu peut dire qui
est le seul acheteur de soins peut dire
à un médecin vous je ne vous veux plus
sont entendus je ne veux plus parce que
vous me coûtait trop cher c'est que les
médecins s'autocensurent qu'au lieu de
soigner les malades en leur âme et
conscience comme ils ont envie de les
soigner parce qu'ils pensent que c'est
bon pour le malade qui se dit si je fais
tel traitement ou tel médicament la sécu
ne gardera plus m'expliqueras du système
de santé les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques sont aussi dans le
collimateur de la cnam
le plan envisage une petite révolution
tous les médicaments d'une même
catégorie qu'il soit cher ou pas
seraient remboursés au prix le plus bas
une manière d'inciter le patient a exigé
le meilleur marché à son pharmacien
pour sa part la cnam demande à l'assuré
de rester fidèle à son médecin
remboursement à 100% s'ils utilisent le
carnet de santé 60 % seulement pour les
autres le plan prévoit aussi un meilleur
remboursement de la médecine au
quotidien comme les soins dentaires ou
les lunettes
en revanche plus question de
subventionner les cures ces propositions
ont été mal accueillie par les
professionnels de la santé
la ministre de l'emploi et de la
solidarité martine aubry devra donc
trancher au mois d'octobre
c'était aujourd'hui les premiers
résultats du baccalauréat général 1999
figurait pour cette épreuve un peu plus
de 344 mille candidats pour l'instant et
pas de statistiques définitives puisque
les oraux de rattrapage vont se
poursuivre jusqu'au 9 juillet mais la
journée fut pleine d'émotion pour ceux
qui se rendaient dans leur centre
d'examen découvrir ou non s'il figurait
bien sur la liste des gagnants
reportage à versailles au lycée jules
ferry avec ellen hughes et jean louis
doucet
jamais ils n'ont franchi la porte du
lycée avec autant de précipitation c'est
sans doute l'espoir d'en sortir très
vite qui leur fait ainsi accélérer le
pas
la marque assez bien sur le tableau
d'affichage
un seul mot et leur vie bascule j'avais
raison
mention admis c'est la délivrance la
joie éclate toi que je vais réaliser
plus ce soir là c'est admis c'est aussi
l'occasion de régler quelques comptes
la preuve devait pas mais j'ai vécu à
côté de la liste des admis celle des
refusés joies et peines côtoient mais
finalement on se fait une raison
nous coûte 5 vous que de 3 j'ai
l'impression que la nouvelle épreuve en
histoire à johanna est très bizarrement
qu'aux régions ces poteaux
et puis il ya ceux pour qui le suspense
va se prolonger ils ont obtenu entre 8
et 10 de moyenne
il leur reste une chance d'être repêché
demain ou après-demain au genre de
rattrapage me disais mais pourquoi c'est
comme si tu récupères te poses médecins
pointent deux groupes dont ils vont
sortir ce soir ils vont s'amuser pas moi
moi je rêve
15 mais c'est pas grave
je vois ça je le voudrais aussi touba 99
ne sera connue qu'après les oraux de
rattrapage dans toute la france
l'an dernier près de 79% des candidats
avaient obtenu le précieux diplôme
voilà et si vous voulez connaître tous
les résultats du bac 99 et bien c'est
sur le minitel 36 15 codes france 2 en
algérie le président abdelaziz
bouteflika fait ce qu'il avait annoncé
lors de sa campagne électorale il a
signé les grâces de plusieurs milliers
d'islamistes sans doute 5000 c'était sa
priorité des priorités mettre un terme
une guerre civile qui aura fait je vous
le rappelle depuis sept ans plus de cent
mille morts les premiers libérés l'ont
été ce matin mais d'autres mesures
notamment la levée de l'état d'urgence
ainsi que la possible libération de
hauts responsables du fisc le front
islamique du salut pourrait être annoncé
prochainement peut-être même dès ce soir
commentaires thierry thulliez avec le
reportage de morne wang li et haberman
bouzidi c'est l'un des premiers à
bénéficier de la mythique scène de
retrouvailles sous les yeux de gendarmes
impassible scènes inimaginables il ya
peu encore en algérie
environ trente prisonniers islamistes
ont été libérés de la prison de haute
sécurité de serkadji surplombe la casbah
d'alger
aucun en principe n'a tué ou n'a été
impliqué directement dans des crimes de
sang ou des viols
ils avaient été condamnés à de courtes
peines de prison j'ai fait quatre ans et
quatre mois dit celui-ci et j'ai appris
seulement ce matin que j'étais libre
toutes les familles présentes n'ont pas
eu la même chance
il resterait plusieurs centaines de
détenus à libérer de serkadji mais
chacun alors dit sa gratitude pour le
geste présidentiel
tout le monde est heureux aujourd'hui je
souhaite qu'ils soient tous relâchés
on oublie tout ça la décision du
président est un acte courageux
la décision du président formidable qui
nous a réconciliés avec nos mains d'el
jadeyaoui la tête de la poule au blanc
auprès de ces familles il a désormais
l'image d'un faiseur de paix abdelaziz
bouteflika a plus c'est en trois mois
que liamine zeroual en plus de trois ans
mais le président sait que ce premier
geste n'a été possible que grâce à la
neutralité bienveillante de l'armée
c'est là où vous êtes armé qui s'est
employé à rassurer à l'occasion de la
fête de l'indépendance
j'ai besoin de vous at il dit à ses
officiers pour rétablir la paix et
l'harmonie nationale
mais l'armée sait que le temps joue pour
abdelaziz bouteflika la population s'est
lassé des violences et les jeunes comme
nassim un repenti du gia libéré après
dix mois de prison sont les meilleurs
propagandistes du pouvoir algérien
nassim s'adresse aux jeunes ne fait
jamais ce que j'ai fait parce que je
suis de vous et je vous dis que c'est
ce que c'est une grave je serai ce qu'on
a fait l'asim attend désormais la loi de
concorde civile
une fois votée elle lui permettra de
tourner la page de six ans de mac et
désire soir c'était tout un symbole d'un
nouvelle ère de liberté avec le concert
de cheb mami sur l'esplanade du
sanctuaire des martyrs alger des
dizaines de milliers de jeunes ont
assisté à cette première manifestation
de musique raï donné par cheb mami
depuis plus de dix ans reportage
marie-jo jouant et patrick des shakers
pour attaquer le conserve une profession
de foi bladi hadji zaïr mon pays
l'algérie
plus je m'éloigne plus je souffre un
acte d'amour un acte et d'encouragement
après dix ans de silence
le chef magnon fearnet la fête de la
jeunesse sous le signe de l'espoir
il a fait venir
oh
ici 75% de la population a moins de 30
ans 50 % moins de 15 ans pour tous ces
jeunes avenue de cheb mami les plus
fortes dans l'idée qu'une page va enfin
se tourner après sept ans de sale guerre
surtout procès lors s est alors estimé
siew c'est pour moi c'est un médicament
qui calme qui cale map cette douleur de
solides solitude désespoir c'est mon job
deux romances et le
le mourad
de mon fait
comment c'est que tous les artistes
algériens 30 même
je pense que les 30 millions d'algériens
ils devraient faire de même c'est parce
que les artistes nous faut que tout le
monde participe sans doute les vestiges
du terrorisme
alger les terrasses sont encore rares
pourtant les jeunes ont décidé de parier
à nouveau et de s'ouvrir au monde
on est en charge de la honte des cigares
sont eux en se marrant sortent en boîte
par la plage au paradis fine mais c'est
à relever le défi c c'est par contre
sans combattre le désactiver c'est
combattre un autre manière lens promène
en sort et au sahel pour qu'on ne chante
pas les voir ce soir même fille plane
famille leur désir que d'autres artistes
reviennent ce jour là le cinéaste
alexandre arcady enfants d'alger a
profité du repérage de son prochain film
pour servir de guide à cheb mami leurs
années au delà de l'écouter il m'en
voudra pas j'écouterai là
le peuple d'alger qui reprendra en
choeur les chansons j'en suis sûr parce
que ça va être un moment incroyable
plus de 100000 algérois déchaîner sur la
place du sanctuaire des martyrs
reprenant en choeur le gagne étude de
chaises manie algéro france résolument
vous à la fête en turquie un nouvel
attentat à l'explosif aujourd'hui à
adana c'est dans le sud du pays un
attentat suicide à la bombe commis par
une femme devant une gendarmerie bilan
un mort et 14 blessés ce serait une
nouvelle action du parti des
travailleurs du kurdistan le pkk cette
organisation a revendiqué l'attentât
commis jeudi dernier à elazig dans l'est
de la turquie attentat qui avait fait
six morts au kosovo dans le sud ouest du
territoire arabe et la csac va des
milliers d'albanais du kosovo assistait
aujourd'hui aux funérailles des 64
victimes d'un massacre perpétré le 25
mars dernier des policiers
paramilitaires serbes seraient les
auteurs de ce massacre où cet enfant de
moins de 10 ans périt commenté patrice
rundle 64 portrait pour autant de
victimes à bela tarr 20 les funérailles
obéissent à un rituel qui commence par
l'hommage des villageois aux martyrs et
se poursuit par le défilé des hommes de
lui ces cas devant les vieux le reste
n'est que sanglots et douleur exprimée
sans retenue avant que la foule gagne
les hauteurs de la ville où les hommes
ont préalablement creuser les tombes
combien sont ils dans le sillage des
couronnes de fleurs en paille a bien
plus en tout cas que les 2800 habitants
de la bourgade qui au matin du 25 mars
dernier alors que l'otan déclenché ses
bombardements contre la yougoslavie voit
débarquer police et paramilitaires
serbes
les maisons seront pillé puis brûlé les
plus chanceux auront le temps de fuir
quand aux autres
parmi les victimes sept enfants âgés de
1 à 10 ans si l'on en croit les légistes
britannique de scotland yard a chargé de
l'autopsié des corps enfants adultes
même traitement
tu mets à bout portant disait enquêteurs
dont les conclusions ont été versés à
l'acte d'accusation du tribunal pénal
international pour slobodan milosevic
pour crime contre l'humanité selon les
autorités de belgrade plus de cent mille
serbes et autres réfugiés non-albanais
aurait fui le kosovo depuis la mi juin
c'est à dire depuis le retrait des
forces yougoslaves et tandis que le haut
commandement militaire de l'otan
confirmé la possibilité d'un déploiement
prochain des forces de paix russes au
kosovo à mitrovica les soldats français
de la kfor la force internationale
s'employait à eux à maintenir le calme
dans la ville et il utilise pour cela
des méthodes bien un aveu des méthodes
plutôt douce
reportage anne consigny et bruno l'hiver
tous les soldats du 21e rima commence à
avoir leurs habitudes
ça fait maintenant quinze jours qu'ils
patrouillent toutes les nuits dans mais
trop vite ça on
la ville est calme elle al'air vie mais
ce n'est qu'une impression
ici première étape de la tournée une
assemblée in anger de serbes de
musulmans et d'albanais weil prépare
pour se rassurer
une coexistence que les hommes d'hassan
fragile alors ils passent tous les soirs
petit à petit de collecter du
rationnement de comprendre ce qui se
passe de comprendre pourquoi ils ont
peur de comprendre où ils sont encore
dehors alors qu'il est minuit minuit et
demi et on a beaucoup de mal à beaucoup
de mal à comprendre et beaucoup de mal à
ce qu'ils nous ce qui ce livre parce
qu'en fait même si son ensemble même si
les uns ont protégé les autres sont pas
en confiance
en quinze jours les endroits sensibles
ont été repérés très famille d'albe
année par exemple du côté
majoritairement serbe de la ville la
maison a été mitraillé il y a dix jours
le non plus ne dorment pas ils n'ont pas
encore vu la patrouille et s'inquiète le
père montre furtivement une arme de
poing censé les protéger
on leur explique que deux soldats ont
été postées dans le quartier avec des
lunettes de vision nocturne comme
sociaux
c'est l'autre technique utilisée par les
patrouilles de nuit elle a déjà servi
lors de plusieurs arrestations des
civils qui n'avait rien du tout qui
pensait pas qu'on les voyait et qui en
fin de compte on est complètement visuel
sur eux depuis long depuis un moment et
n'avait plus qu'à aller choper en deux
semaines les veillées nocturnes des
soldats français de la kfor sont devenus
de plus en plus calme c'est patrouilles
de surveillance ont aussi permis de ne
pas placer la ville sous couvre-feu en
france sur le continent comme sur l'île
corse les incendies qui s'étaient
déclarés ces dernières 48 heures ont été
maîtrisés mais ne sont pas encore
complètement éteint le ministre de
l'intérieur jean pierre chevènement
appelé ce matin lors d'un déplacement
dans le département de l'hérault à la
prudence et à la vigilance de chacun
et puis le ministre a assisté à une
démonstration de canadair c'est en effet
une date anniversaire
cela fait trente ans que les canadairs
sont en activité
le premier décollage eu lieu en 1969 sur
la base de marignane dans les bouches du
rhône
aujourd'hui 11 appareils sont
opérationnels et efficaces 80 pilotes de
ses bombardiers d'eau effectué les
différentes rotations de lutte contre
les incendies alors voici le reportage
de joël bruandet et yann moins
réalisé en leur compagnie et quatre
écoles à plus cher ce devait être une
journée calme à marignane avec quelques
échos page d'entraînement sur l'étang de
berre
les prêts en 12 secondes ce canadair à
avaler 6000 litres d'eau 14 heures la
base de la sécurité civile somnolent par
30° allons les équipages dallaire tu ne
rêves pas d'entraînement il ne pense
qu'à une chose la mission sur feu ces
anciens militaires ont tous renoncé à
être pilote de ligne il préfère les
incendies et l'ambiance de la base
malgré un salaire d'environ 20000 francs
soit deux fois moins que dans les
compagnies aériennes ils savent
qu'aujourd'hui il y a toutes les chances
pour qu'on les appelle depuis quinze
jours ils sont déjà intervenus sur une
dizaine de feux importants
nous sommes actuellement dans une
situation plus préoccupante que les
années presque la nisa des précédentes
et la situation météorologique actuelle
liée aux conditions climatiques est une
situation de fin juillet c'est à dire
pratiquement un mois d'avancé par
rapport à des situations normales
en moins d'un quart d'heure l'appareil
doit être prêt à partir
même si la destination n'est pas encore
précis
je n'avais pas envie de se montrer
encore mai
l'information
en une après-midi deux puis quatre
canadair vont partir pour sands a en
corse du sud après une heure de vol les
pilotes découvrent l' incendie qui
dévore lentement une forêt de résineux
presque s'enflamme le feu parcours les
sous bois
une centaine de sapeurs pompiers sont
déjà sur place ce sont eux qui vont
guider les largages il n'arrive pas
l'éteindre en dessous dans les
transferts
les remèdes normandie caen rennes
chaque largage est une affaire de
précision et demande une concentration
sans faille à zonza les canadairs
effectueront au total 130 rotation soit
près de 800 tonnes d'eau déversées sur
le feu
le peut pour nous cette équipe en
quelques heures c'est comme une personne
mais c'est un ennemi qu on essaye c'est
un pas un jeu mais
et très tactique on essaye de le coincer
on essaye de le tuer en finale
bon on la réponse à l'expression sur la
très pratique
lors des écopages en bord de mer comme
ici à ajaccio les pilotes ont en effet
toujours à l'esprit le danger que
représentent les plaisanciers et parfois
même des nageurs attirés par le
spectacle mais inconscients des risques
à partir du 15 juillet cinq avions
bombardiers d'eau quitteront marignane
pour ceux basés en corse un appui
indispensable car les moyens terrestres
sont ici dix fois moins important que
sur le continent
est ce que ça représente comme appui là
pour vous les canadairs beaucoup surtout
quand c'est pas accessible on appui
aérien très important et nous aide
beaucoup
pompiers et canadair auront mis 3 jours
et 2 nuits pour venir à bout de
l'incendié de zonza bilan 80 hectares
partis en fumée moins de deux ans après
l'accident dont fut victime à paris la
princesse de galles lady diana le
dossier d'instruction sur les conditions
de cet accident vient d'être transmis au
parquet de paris dans trois mois maximum
on saura si les juges français en
décider ou non d'un procès pour les
protagonistes
les photographes de presse mise en cause
depuis un mois maintenant en russie
c'est une canicule terrible qui
sévissent des dizaines de personnes sont
mortes selon des agences de presse de
saint pétersbourg chaque jour des
prisonniers meurent de chaleur dans
l'établissement pénitentiaire de la
ville
à moscou comme dans plusieurs autres
villes du centre de la russie
les effets d'un soleil très abondantes
provoquent des séries de malaise
meurtrier gilles rabin et progressait
pour le reportage heureusement depuis la
fin de l'ère communiste
on pense aux des fontaines un peu
partout dans moscou quand on a 15 ans et
qui fait plus de 30 degrés depuis plus
d'un mois on peut décider d'en faire une
piscine
moscou n'a pas connu pareille canicule
aussi dur aussi l'omni paris sécheresse
depuis un demi-siècle 1953 exactement la
vie va changer de visage ses habitants
aussi
mais les vieilles habitudes ont la vie
dure pour se désaltérer les russes
boivent de la bière dès le matin et
souvent de l'alcool
même les jeunes même les mêmes résultats
122 morts par noyade presque tous parce
qu'ils étaient libres avant de se
baigner les berges de la moskova et des
lacs
il s'emploiera capitale russe sont
envahis et même les jours de semaine
je viens tous les jours il fait
tellement chaud qu'un jour de
récupération pour que ma femme et mes
enfants restent pas enfermés à la maison
et puis se baigner et bon j'ai un poney
la canicule est d'autant plus difficile
à supporter que cette année conséquences
des crises économiques
deux russes sur trois ne pourront pas se
payer de vacances regarde comme la soif
dans les jardins familiaux des petites
datcha de la périphérie de moscou c'est
une inquiétude
l'eau manque il faut aller la chercher
de plus en plus loin 20 minutes ici et
comment vous faites on fait comme ça
c'est les zones qui vont la chercher
nous on arrose la récolte de ces arpents
privé c'est une question de survie pour
la plupart des familles qu'ils étaient
cultivées elle même ce qu'elle mange
rond pendant l'hiver plus grave des
incendies de forêt commencent à éclater
aux portes de moscou
le feu peut se déclarer n'importe où à
n'importe quel moment
car le feu couve et court sous la terre
dans la tourbe
la situation est sous contrôle mais il
ne faudrait pas que la canicule et la
sécheresse dure encore trop longtemps du
sport du cyclisme avec la deuxième étape
du tour de france challans saint nazaire
176 kilomètres à parcourir avec un
passage du gois entre bellevue
fromentine et l'île de noirmoutier
plutôt difficile et même délicat et à
l'arrivée à un nouveau maillot jaune et
de gros écarts entre certains grands
favoris
commentaire de nathanaël de rincquesen
avec alain poirier aujourd'hui pour voir
passer le clou il fallait se mouiller
presque jusqu'aux bollée
ces touristes sont des spectateurs et
cette route c'est tout simplement celle
des coureurs
un peut pas supprimer la salle
si tout le monde n'a pas eu le courage
d'affronter la marée certains ont
carrément coupé à travers les champs
d'algues pour être bien placé sur le
bois de noirmoutier inconvénients du
bateau une fois placé vous ne pouvez
plus bouger mais un voilier bien échouer
peux t'offrir un point de vue unique
pour voir passer le tour principale
difficulté de l'étape du jour
l'horaire des marées et l'état de la
route pendant près d'une heure juste
avant le passage des coureurs
la direction départementale de
l'équipement a dû nettoyer le gua de ses
spectateurs indésirables
c'est chaud allez voir ça va quand même
les habitudes il ya là plus que ça et là
c'est peut-être trouvé des meilleurs
l'hydroglisseur voilà bien le meilleur
moyen pour voir le peloton progressé
tout au long des quatre km du bois de
noirmoutier
le bois devait marquer les esprits il va
laisser des traces
une chute collective au milieu du
peloton entraîne un embouteillage la
chaussée est étroite
104 coureurs sont pris au piège par
mieux quelques favoris joue le rin et
robotique brochard ils arriveront à
saint nazaire
avec plus de 6 minutes de retard sur ce
groupe de soixante dix échappés bien
malgré eux sur la ligne d'arrivée tom
steels s'impose juste devant jan
kirsipuu quercy pu très habile
aujourd'hui notamment lors des sprints
bonifications a repris 30 secondes à
lance armstrong vient plus qu'il n'en
fallait pour dépasser l'américain au
classement général et au pire à
l'estonie le premier maillot jaune de
son histoire avant de refermer ce
journal je voudrais saluer la mémoire de
xavier gélin ce comédien réalisateur et
producteur de cinéma vient de mourir
d'un cancer à l'âge de 53 ans
xavier gélin était le fils de danièle
delorme et daniel gélin il avait le
sourire de l'amitié nous arrivons à la
fin de ce journal je rappelle deux
informations nous avons développé
l'offre publique d'échangé lancée par le
groupe pétrolier total fina sur elf pour
devenir le quatrième producteur mondial
l'état ne s'opposera pas cet éventuel
rapprochement
et puis en algérie les premiers
prisonniers smith gracié par le
président bouteflika sont sortis de
prison signifiant peut-être le début une
nouveau changement de la politique
algérienne
dans quelques secondes la météo avec
sophie davant à 0 heures 15 le journal
de la nuit vous sera présenté par
florence duprat demain 7h 50 dans les 4
vérités
françoise laborde recevra michel louis
lewicki démographe et rédacteur en chef
de population et sociétés à l'ined
ce sont les premiers résultats des
recensements et puis à 13h vous
retrouverez carole gaessler et rachid
arhab sur la route du tour de france à
demain 20h bonsoir merci
tous